begin with breaking news out of Southern
Lebanon where we're getting reports that
three Hezbollah members have been killed
in another targeted Israeli strike the
attack on a car happened in the southern
town of gandu and it comes a day after a
drone attack killed one of hezbollah's
top commanders wisam Alta his due to be
buried in the area later today let's
bring in Zena hudder who's on the line
for us from Southern Lebanon so Zena
what more do we know about this latest
uh targeted
killing well what we understand is that
there were three people in that vehicle
members of the Lebanese armed group
Hezbollah and car was hit by an apparent
Israeli drone strike the second attack
of its kind in as many days the attack
happened in gandu we were on that road
we were very close to that Village
because we were making our way to bsim
where the Hezbollah senior field
commander was is is going to be buried
and he was killed in herbet Sim just 24
hours ago so as you can imagine the
situation is escalating targeted attacks
assassinations seem to be Israel's new
strategy this will be the sixth targeted
um assassination if you like in in the
past two weeks of commanders or members
of Iran's so-called axis of resistance
so hasbalah has still not commented but
it is in a difficult position because
you have this strike and then
yesterday's strike killing with tail and
a week before its Ally Hamas is number
two men in Lebanon right Sal Al Ari was
killed in a heah stronghold so it
appears
hasah yes yeah it appears Zena that
where we're looking at a new campaign of
targeted killings o of Hamas and and
Hezbollah leaders and have you and as
you've said I mean Hezbollah until now
had been trying to avoid an ol out War
how might they respond
now well we have to see whether their
response will be calibrated but I can
tell you since that strike we are
getting reports of multiple launches of
rockets into Northern Israel if what we
have been witnessing for the past three
months since hezb joined the battle
against is to help relieve its Ali Hamas
in Gaza but those Rockets or missile
launches or even drone attacks targeting
Israeli military positions along the
border don't seem to be uh deterring
Israel Israel seems on escalating this
conflict in many ways Israel is
negotiating it is trying to have a
stronger bargaining position as it tries
to pressure the Leese armed group to
move away from the border Israel's
concern right now is to restore security
along its northern front to allow tens
of thousands of Israeli citizens to
return home Hezbollah is not allowing
them to do that and Hezbollah is saying
that they're not ready to discuss
anything until Israel's aggression on
Gaza stops so this is a very dangerous
situation the cycle of violence is
continuing and it is only escalating
okay okay Zena thank you for the moment
that's Zena hoder on the line there from
Southern Lebanon with the the latest on
what appears to be another uh targeted
attack by Israel Israel on members of
the Lebanese group Hezbollah and as Zena
mentioned uh there' have been multiple
rocket launches into Northern Israel
let's speak to Laura Khan about this
she's joining us from schom in Northern
Israel uh rocket Sirens going off near
where you are Laura tell us about what's
happening
rockets and drone Sirens going off uh
not far from where I am it's been
happening in the last two hours all
along the border um I am in a place
called schom it's a town usually of
around 8,000 people at the moment
there's barely anyone here a few
strugglers coming in and out but I just
want to show you why this town is
important you can see just behind us
there's a big zigzag of a wall this
there was a security fence there before
but they've built a wall in the last
couple of years and it's created a real
point of contention with Hamas H sorry
with Hezbollah because just to the right
you have Lebanese territory to the left
is Israeli territory and then just to
the South as you work your way down
there's Israeli homes there and Israel
is trying to push Hezbollah all the way
back to the ridge they say that is a
natural border for them Hezbollah
disagrees with that they say this this
is their land so not only that is
creating a point of contention but also
of course the killing of wisam alil the
Hezbollah commander and in a very
strange break of um ambiguous policy
from Israel uh Israel C newly appointed
foreign minister has admitted that they
did kill him uh so we have heard now
about an attack a hisb attack on a
military base about 20 kilometers away
from us we are trying to confirm that at
the moment um but I just want to show
around us the Israelis have been talking
not only about pushing has back but not
bringing the tens of thousands of
evacuees back along the borders usually
880,000 along this 120 kilm kilometer
border now there's only a few thousand a
few people coming in and out and as you
can see behind me it's a complete ghost
town they say they won't bring them back
until Hezbollah pushes all the way back
by at least 30 kilom certainly a
concession it's not willing to make and
it's really pushing both sides to the
brink of war and there's a lot of
military posturing here but there's also
scars of War here we're walking just
along a a little Ridge along here we saw
smashed Windows everywhere we saw
scattered children's toys and Scar marks
in the ground where mortar has landed so
it's still a very precarious situation
here and we've also seen those uh rocket
Sirens going all the way from the East
and continuing along West to close to
where we are now so a very volatile
situation Laura with reports of a
Hezbollah attack on a military base in
Northern Israel and Rocket sirens and
drone Sirens going off near where you
are of course we'll come back to you
when you have more information about
these latest developments